m on accueille maintenant quelqu'un qui
lui est fait pour l'intervention
américaine en irak
voici andré glucksmann
fonseka
je sais qu'il faut andré glucksmann
bonsoir vous connaissez roger auque non
moi je vous connais de nom je vous
admire beaucoup parce que j'ai failli
faire des études de philosophie donc jeu
j'aime beaucoup
entre pensée et moi j'aime beaucoup vos
reportages on les admire beaucoup parce
que je devais faire sur le devant et
vous rien une pub alors vous andré
glucksmann vous étiez pour
l'intervention américaine en irak
1 et vous êtes contre l'intervention
russe en tchétchénie
oui pourquoi écoutez je pense que c'est
pas comparable
je suis assez de la vie de roger auque
sur niera que le bilan qu'une terme
paraît juste mais les russes ce n'est
pas la liberté qu'ils apportaient en
tchétchénie même pas l'intention de
liberté les russes mènent une guerre
coloniale depuis 300 ans en tchétchénie
le jard voulait les mers chaudes et puis
il a trouvé un petit peuple de
montagnards de moins d'un million
d'habitants qui lui a résisté pendant 30
ans
le moins d'un million d'habitants s'est
retrouvé à 80 milles
c'était une guerre d'extermination
terrible c'est une guerre coloniale
épouvantable deuxième étape
staline en 1944 il des portes en trois
jours sous les directions de beria
derrien c'était la gestapo
oui mais la gestapo c'était 30 millions
de gens qui ont été envoyés par le dans
le goulag par béria ils ont été obligés
de le tuer iberia tellement il était
dangereux hills et les autres membres du
politique bureau 1 en trois jours tous
envoyés au goulag le tiers meurent
pendant le voyage mais il y avait une
partie qui n'allait n'était pas
transportable elle était brûlée sur
place troisième étape
une guerre qui dure depuis dix ans qui
probablement a coûté aux personnes ne
fait les comptes sains mais entre 100000
et 300000 tchétchène proportionnellement
la france ça fait environ 15 millions de
morts pour la main par rapport à la
population de mort c'est à dire qu'il ya
trois fois plus d'handicapés de blessés
de terribles alors rien de comparable
c'est la pire des guerres qui est mené
depuis dix ans c'est un épouvantable
massa et nous nous restons absolument
pas siffler à devant alors j'ai toujours
dit que ça allait mener deux désastres
en désastre au pilori et la baisse lane
c'est le pire le pire terrorisme ça ne
s'est jamais vu un dé suspendre des
explosifs au dessus des bébés au dessus
des gosses 1 les obliger à boire leur
pipi c'est quand même le crime contre
l'humanité absolue cela définit le
risque que nous courons nous parce qu'un
type qui est capable
un type sont plusieurs c'est quand même
s' il le revendique c'est qu'il ya une
certaine popularité dans tout le caucase
à ce genre de choses ce qu'ils sont
capables de prendre en otage des enfants
de suspendre et c'est tout ce qu'on a vu
en sachant d'ailleurs que les otages
seraient tués parce qu'ils savent
comment les russes conduisent équipe
tire dans le tas ce qui les rend encore
plus coupable même si les russes sont
pas innocents ce qu'ils sont capables de
faire ça sont aussi capables de se
fracasser sur une centrale nucléaire
or vous savez que cela est possible en
russie beaucoup plus facile aux états
unis korité en gros andré glucksmann
c'est que quand on est capable de
prendre en otage une école comme on est
capable de faire sauter de tchernobyl
oui le ou d'autres tchernobyl en russie
ou en biélorussie en ukraine et c'est
pour ça que je dis cela depuis dix ans
je crie depuis dix ans 1 1 que la voix
afghane
si elle se répète en tchétchénie c'est
un nouveau manhattan parce que
l'afghanistan ces dix années d'armée
rouge mais c'est et russell a pas
changer d'armé russes en afghanistan
pillages pour les mers chaudes un oui
toujours
dévastation un résultat le désert tout
est cassé
pas seulement le physique mais aussi une
morale 1 les plus fanatiques s'installe
où les plus gangster mme les deux les
taliban ben laden et boum manhattan
alors si on veut recommencer ce petit
jeu et c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire je dis que de la part des
responsables occidentaux
c'est une irresponsabilité par jean
aubert il faudrait qu aujourd'hui les
responsables occidentaux disent à
poutine laissez la tchétchénie comme
comme la france a laissé l'algérie par
exemple c'est ça que je voulais dire
mais pourquoi d'ailleurs oui ou non mais
écoutez moi je suis pour pour soutenir
massoud quand il est temps on ne l'a pas
soutenu qu'en fin était temps
quatre mois avant sa mort il est venu en
france on était cinq c'est vrai à le
recevoir
1 or s'il avait pris kaboul 3 - ben
n'aurait pas eu manhattan ben laden
aurait dû faire autre truc enfin en tout
cas il n'avait pas sa base il y à un as
ou d' en tchétchénie il est pour
l'instant encore vivant malgré sa tête
m'a pris par poutine traitons avec lui
est ce que andré est ce qu'aujourd'hui
les occidentaux les pays occidentaux ont
la puissance suffisante pour obliger
poutine à se réconcilier ou à se
concilier disons avec avec maskhadov
poutine est un homme qui quand il
résonne tout seul résonnent en officier
de police de la gestapo est russe en
tchéquie il l'a dit il a dit tchékistes
un jour ce qui ce toujours le cas
c'est le truc de béria
il ya une différence par contre c'est un
être rationnel
chaque fois qu'il ya eu des pressions
suffisamment forte
il a accepté ce qu'il n'avait pas envie
d'accepter rien que leur attachement au
pacte atlantique
deux des pays baltes sert à kaliningrad
toujours il a accepté
peut-être donnant donnant 1 1 on peut
offrir des crédits on peut lui offrir de
l'aide mais je trouve qu'il est
complètement irresponsable de notre part
de laisser pourrir tout le coca est ce
que vous croyez pas que poutine
maintenant il est parti dans l'autre
sens c'est à dire qu'il est en train de
se radicaliser lui même et qui refait
finalement de de la russie ce qu'elle
était du temps des des bolcheviks pas
tout à fait parce qu'il n'ya pas
l'idéologie lloris vous pourrez pas les
convaincre qu'elle communisme à l'avenir
du monde c'est fini
j'appelle les uns eu leur ration ce
lundi ce qu'il a compris c'est que plus
on c'est un principe pas seulement
stalinien mais aussi du dard plus on
tape sur les tchétchènes plus c'est la
bonne occasion pour sous prétexte de
lutte antiterroriste interdire les mass
médias il ya plus une télévision qui
soient libres en 1 6 et puis maintenant
à pro après belson qu'est-ce qui se
passe il modifie la loi électorale
il nomme les gouverneurs et nomme les
gouverneurs le lendemain le du
11-septembre dix ans bah maintenant les
gouverneurs c'est moi qui les nomme
wayne et puis je change les lois
électorales jeune homme les députés ce
que je veux il repart quand même vers la
dictature
oui et alors c'est d'autant plus
dangereux pour l'europe masque d'une
part il ya des gens comme bassaïev
qu'ils sont capables de faire n'importe
quoi donc aussi des explosions
nucléaires ou autre chose il faut vous
rappeler quand même que la dame
tchétchène probablement qui a pris
l'avion qu'il a fait sauter un elle à
payer 40 euros pour pouvoir monter dans
l'avion
elle a acheté bakchich un policier pour
40 euros
un autre qui a mis deux voitures c'est
le fsb qui raconte ça inquiète mis deux
voitures qui devait exploser son trajet
de poutine l'a fait pour 1000 $ alors à
ce prix on peut faire n'importe quoi en
russie alors roger haut que ça vous
donne pas envie d'aller en tchétchénie
tout ça moi j'ai vu un
quand j'étais à bagdad j'ai vu en direct
la à la télévision lalala cette prise
d'otage moi ça m'a rendu malade pendant
deux trois jours justement j'ai trouvé
ça mais c'est monstrueux c'est ce qu'ils
ont fait assez à ses enfants mais ça m'a
vraiment rendu malade je crois que c'est
la première fois en 25 ans de métier je
n'ai même plus envie de faire des
papiers pour sur balles d'ailleurs irak
et l'irak paraissait complètement
inintéressant après ça je trouve que
c'est le paroxysme de cette monstruosité
des terroristes et extrémistes veneris
comme des incroyables
attendez moi ce que je crains et c'est
pas pour deux trois jours que je que ces
images m'obsède c'est jusqu'à la fin de
mes jours
je peux vous dire que quand j'étais môme
à 5 ans j'ai vu les gendarmes qui
emmenait les gens juifs des jeunes
ma mère a résisté je suis pas parti elle
non plus mais depuis ce temps là ce qui
m'obsède c'est le silence entier du
monde entier devant ce genre de choses
or en tchétchénie il ya quarante mille
gosse qui sont morts du fait de
l'invasion russe
donc là il ya quelque chose qui m'obsède
c'est notre silence mais pour une fois
je sais que je raterais ma vie parce que
si on n'arrête pas ça tout ce que j'ai
fait n'a aucun sens
mais le mot humanité n'a pas de sens non
plus parce que quand il ya les tutsis
c'est un génocide 10 passes en trois
mois on a à peine le temps de comprendre
qu'on peut plus intervenir mais là ça
dure depuis dix ans 1 1 et on ne fait
rien alors si ça nous retombe dessus
si les gens deviennent non pas fous de
dieu mais coûte douleur
et s'il ya quelques imbéciles
dégueulasse comme ceux de beslan qui
font n'importe quoi je serais pas étonné
ce que j'ai vu moi beslan c'est la fin
du monde ces mômes ses moments perdus en
petite culotte ensanglanté les yeux
exorbités cours entre deux feux les
journalistes qui font des reportages
mais qui n'ont plus idée de ce qui se
passe et tu peuvent pas nous en donner
une idée les autorités qui manque qui
disent il ya trois cents 300 otages
alors qu'elles savent très bien qu'on a
plus de 1000 1
les parents qui sont complètement
affolée autour et qui se baladent avec
des tromblons et qui vont vous vont
tirer dans dans n'importe quoi les
spetsnaz les troupes spéciales russes
qui vont foncer dans le tas
personne pour négocier pendant un jour
et demi il n'y a pas eu une négociation
les gosses crever de soif de faim et ses
rails de frayeur surtout donc ça moi
pour moi c'est la fin du monde alors la
fin du monde quand vous la vivez vous ne
voyez pas quand vous la voyez vous ne
vivez pas encore eh bien c'est ce pas
encore qui m'obsède
à